Okay, let's go to our caller from the 267 area code who's calling from 2 6 7 today
It should be Jimmy from Chloe. Hey, Jimmy, what's going on?
well, you know, you know David I
Hear you talking about are you in a good face of meaningful?
Conversations and yet the way I heard you just described Trump supporters was in bad things. You can three subsections
One or ignorant to two retarded or three to bad people. How is that a good faith argument?
To tell me that David. How is that?
having a meaningful conversation
Well explain to me someone who's outside of those three categories
Okay, why did you vote for Trump
What do you mean what why not go for Tom my god, the reasons are because because I can't stand politicians
Because they've been lying for years. Hey, hey, let's take them one by one. Let's take them one by one
If you voted for Trump because you don't like politicians
I would consider that an ignorant reason to vote for Trump
Your second reason was because other politicians lie Trump lies all the time. That's also not a good
Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy, hold on a second. Let's take it one step at a time
The two reasons you cited for voting for Trump. I would characterize as extraordinarily
Ignorant, so you're not providing where she would because you don't like Trump
Of course you would know
Hold on a second, Jimmy if you called and you said I voted for any
candidate because politicians lie, I would consider that an ignorant reason it has nothing to do and
Now you describe that. How is that ignorant? Because it's true
Politicians do lines let's face it. We know it. You don't know there's that the why does the fact that
politician because I think the vision because I think
Erupting me. I'm gonna hang up on you
You still there Jimmy? Yeah, I'm here. Okay my question is how is
reaching the decision
To vote for any particular candidate because in history politicians have lied not ignorant
You're adding more to it, I don't know I just give you a sampling answer David Jimmy Jimmy, why are you so angry?
Because you just been followed every Trump supporter, and I don't like that day, but you're disingenuous
No, actually, I was completely genuine in my analysis
Number two to retard it another three to bad people Jimmy record David Ellis had a good faith argument
Jimmy can we take it one day at a time or is that not possible?
David you know what you're annoying. I'm hanging up on you. Okay. Thank you, man. Jimmy just shot out of a cannon